developed to protect artwork from the
damages of dust inspired by gecko feet
researchers from Yale developed a non
sticky plastic sheet that produces
enough electrostatic charge to remove
dust from a surface by attaching it to
micro pillar structures and an arachnid
preserved in iron carbonate for 305
million years was recently analyzed
using computed tomography and it turns
out it's a previously unknown creature
that's a lot like a spider Vsauce Kevin
here this is mind blow the way your
brain thinks could be your new password
researchers at Binghamton University
have developed a new brain biometric
that uses the brains response to a
series of images to identify you with
100% accuracy
so while wearing an EEG system a
specific change in voltage at the scalp
is recorded reacting to images of
certain celebrities or uncommon words
and then used as a passcode and the
images can be changed which unlike your
fingerprints or retinas allows you to
change your brain password the major
challenge is translating this system to
a consumer product one of the most
advanced wings tunnels in the world is
being used to learn the flight secrets
of birds drones currently have a hard
time stabilizing in turbulent conditions
so the new wind tunnel allows
researchers from Stanford University to
analyze how birds react to different
turbulence patterns bearing in mind the
safety of the birds they don't crank up
the speed to uncomfortable levels and in
the future more advanced aerial robot
designs will undergo testing in this
wind tunnel the Stanford robotics lab
has created a robotic mermaid for
exploring the ocean ocean one is an
underwater humanoid with stereoscopic
vision and force sensors on its hands
and provide haptic feedback to the pilot
giving the human a feel for the objects
providing a physical avatar for humans
to dive in study areas of the ocean too
dangerous for people it's already been
used to explore the wreck of king louis
xiv flagship previously out of reach for
humans and it has recovered artifacts
a I cure hopes to monitor track and make
sure patients are taking their
medication they claim half of all
patients don't take medication as
prescribed so this app visually confirms
the proper medication confirms the
proper user ingests it and does so at
the proper time it's customizable and
adapts to patient behavior the data can
be accessed by medical providers and can
recognize improper or suspicious use and
they hope this can reduce the reported
198 billion dollars spent on
hospitalizations resulting from improper
medication use each year researchers at
the University of California Berkeley
have charted sub regions of the brain
that responds to different words the
semantic system map displays the
organization of words based on meanings
like people time number tactile outdoor
or place this single brain combines it
visualizes six different people's word
meaning brain activity hopefully they
can study more subjects from different
cultural upbringing and education to see
how consistent this brain map really is
ultimately it could help understand
language impairments and diseases such
as Alzheimer's mind blow eighty two
uploaded in May 2014
featured Co a handheld spectrometer that
detects the chemical makeup of objects
by scanning them analyzing the data in
the cloud and reporting results on a
smartphone
well the sensors and development tool
kits are now rolling out and can analyze
carbs fat and water dairy meat and
vegetables and also the contents of pain
relieving pills the prospects for mobile
spectrometer technology include not only
eventually building this into a
smartphone itself but using it to detect
counterfeit products compare generic and
name-brand products and also the purity
and differences in drugs
finally a Lu a company in Norway is
developing a swimming snake robot for
subsea maintenance and inspection
I'm gonna leave you with the champion of
real robot battle and as always thanks
for watching
we're all set for auto control
Roger Farber to move to electronic
control strip in center lane you're now
under automatic control hands off
steering ah this is the life safe cool
comfortable
mind if I smoke cigar or not with this
wonderful air conditioning hey you want
some ice cream or a cool drink orange
juice please me too I'm gonna go for the
ice cream
there's automatic sleep control in every
bed and a predigested food is cooked by
infrared